on m'appelle simpl l'innocent du village
tout comme un agnolet je mène la vie
d'un sage chanttin géand moi je visis de
l'air du temps je dois tout ça au
conseil de mon papa je garde son secret
c'est mon seul
héritage complet m'a fait le
SAL les oiseaux sont mes
confidents et quand je siffle entre mes
dents ils me comprennent tous en
som ils sont plus sensibles à mes
[Musique]
mots pour n'être que des
animaux ils sont moins bêtes que les
hommes
voilà pourquoi autour de moi parfois et
tous les
villageois on m'a fait le simpl
l'innocent du
village je mène la vie d'un sage
j'antends guim moi je vis de l'air du
temps je dois tout ça au conseil de mon
papa je garde son secret c'est mon seul
héritage mon bonheur est complet on
m'appelle
simpl je suis je suis un petit peu
Simplé ça ça ça me fait rirece quez je
trouve qu'ils ont l'air complètement
[Musique]
Fada
là et qui est-ce qui n'est pas qui
est-ce qui n'est pas Fada et ben c'est
[Musique]
moi